justicia para matar ver y juez de la
corte superior del georgia eeuu condenó
a cadena perpetua a travis y mcmichael
padre e hijo por asesinato william
bryant el vecino que siguió y fuimos su
crimen os podrá optar a la libertad
condicional después de 30 años en
prisión algo que no podrán hacer los
otros dos sentenciados
a mod albert y fue luego perseguido y
baleado y fue asesinado porque las
personas aquí en esta sala del tribunal
tomaron la ley en sus propios mandos
james avery un hombre de apenas 25 años
había salido de su casa para correr fue
perseguido por los mató michael que lo
siguieron con armas a bordo de una
camioneta william bryant vecino se unió
a la cacería y filmó la escena
finalmente lo acorralaron y travis le
disparó a quemarropa en el juicio los
acusados alegaron que intentaban hacer
un arresto ciudadano ya que sospechaban
de que fuese un ladrón
sin embargo no fueron detenidos hasta
mayo de 2020 cuando se viralizó el vídeo
del asesinato
la madre de amor celebró la condena
[Aplausos]
brand
pero sabía que saldríamos con una
victoria nunca lo dude y sabía que hoy
llegaría
pero el proceso legal todavía no acaba
aquí los condenados serán juzgados en un
tribunal federal para responder por
cargos de crímenes de odio lo que les
podría costar la pena capital- la muerte
de what are very tuvo gran repercusión
se produjo durante las mayores protestas
raciales de los últimos años surgidas
tras el asesinato de georges floyd y la
consecuente reacción del movimiento las
vidas negras importan